we're now on question five people feel a
keen sense of bonding when they sing
together all right so that sentence
seems like it's grammatically correct
let's see what the question says which
choice most effectively establishes the
main topic of the paragraph okay i see
they either want us to say okay we could
have no change and say this sentence is
what we would keep as our topic sentence
or maybe would replace it with one of
these other options well to to figure
out how we could establish the main
topic of the paragraph I guess we're
gonna have to read the paragraph so I
would actually probably come back to
question five after reading after going
all the way through question nine so
let's see if we can do that in this
video singing stimulates the right
temporal lobe of the brain and releases
endorphins endorphins blunt pain and
engender feelings of pleasure so this
right over here so for number six to
just kind of do a period and then do
another sentence it's not grammatically
incorrect i mean it's fine to say that
singing stimulates the right temporal
lobe of the brain releases endorphins
that's a sentence and then to say
endorphins blood pain and engender
feelings of pleasure but these two
sentences are very connected in fact
this the second sentence right over here
is giving us clarity on what endorphins
are so i would i would think about i
would think about kind of connecting
them a little bit better so let's see
what what the choices are what the
choices are here so the first one is
well they actually didn't put no change
here so we they definitely want us to
change it I guess the way this is this
the way this is written written so the
first choice is singing stimulates the
right temporal lobe of the brain and
releases endorphins which end up
blunting and engender feelings of
pleasure no that's not right i mean just
even look you saying end up blunting and
engender those those two verbs aren't
even in the in the in the same in the
same tense blunting blunting yeah this
is you know blunting and engender nope
it's not it's it's breaking your
parallel construction so to speak
endorphins which blunt let's see singing
simply stimulates the right temporal
lobe
the brain releases endorphins which
blunt which blunt pain and engender
feelings of pleasure yeah that one could
work and it connects them better let's
see see endorphins but they blunt no you
don't want to contradict it we're just
explaining with what endorphins do this
last choice endorphins and they blunt no
I think this is very clear when you say
which blunt your clarifying what
endorphins do so I like be there alright
let's keep going so now we can go to
question 7 so cortisol a hormonal
reaction to stress and the secretion of
which the brain controls decreases after
choir singing alright so cortisol the
stress hormone and it decreases after
choir singing meanwhile oxytocin which
the brain interprets as a feeling of
emotional bonding is increase so these
are all describing ways that make people
feel better and I want to read this
entire paragraph because I at the end at
the end I want to go back to question
five and think about the topic sentence
so all of these good things are
happening and a study at Oxford Brookes
University researchers surveyed 375
people who either sang alone sang in a
choir or participated in organized
sports those who sang in choir reported
the highest levels of happy so
everything we're talking about is wow
this choir singing really can make
people happier so and they're kind of
citing even you know chemical you know
the sign we can point to chemical things
happening the brain that are actually
associated with more happiness and less
stress due to its positive side effects
therapists have used choir singing as an
element for those dealing with
depression and chronic pain so I kind of
like the due to its positive side
effects because that is the what reason
why therapist would use its but let's
just look at the let's look at the other
choice the other choices so I like do
too i'm going to des my default so
despite its positive side effects
therapists have used choir singing no i
mean they're using it because of the
size of side effects due to the positive
side effects this isn't a contradiction
to the fact that has positive side
effects it's not you know if it was
despite the fact that it's bad for
people
therapists are using it that would not
would you know that would why that would
be a reason to use the word despite but
no that doesn't make sense in addition
to its positive side effects therapists
have used choir singing as an element
for those dealing with depression and
chronic pain well it's not an addition
it's it's saying it's giving the
causality because it due to its positive
side effects this is why therapists are
thinking about using it as a way to deal
with depression and chronic pain and
then besides once again it's not a
besides the therapists have used choir
singing that's because due to the
positive side effects it isn't on top of
or you know another thing that's
seemingly unrelated so I definitely
would go with no change now let's go to
a question 8 and once again this i'm
using a prototype version where it says
six out of 5 7 out of 5 obviously should
not be out of 5 because there's more
than five questions here let's go to
question 8 so due to its positive side
effects therapists have used choir
singing as an element for those dealing
with depression and chronic pain an
element feels a little weird an element
of what let's see what the other what
the what the other options are an
accessory for those dealing with
depression and chronic pain an accessory
I imagine more of a bit of a you know it
wouldn't be a process like or choir
singing it wouldn't be an activity I
wouldn't call it an activity an
accessory a or piece I mean well
accessory doesn't feel doesn't feel
right there let's see choir singing as a
supplement for those dealing with
depression and chronic pain a supplement
could be good because you know you
wouldn't make this the primary treatment
if someone has severe depression or
chronic pain you wouldn't just say hey
why don't you go start in a quiet go
start singing in a choir there's other
things that the therapist would probably
do to to help alleviate or deal with the
depression and chronic pain but it would
be a supplement above and beyond above
and beyond what kind of the more
traditional methods might be this could
be something to do on top of that now in
addendum and addendum once again this is
like something that you add on to other
things and so it kind of is like a
supplement but you know I view an
addendum to kind of a presentation at a
computer or
to a to a kind of a position paper or
something something I add on to the back
of something like that like a proposal I
don't I don't I wouldn't use that word
if I'm talking about you know kind of
treatment or dealing with with with
something and that's kind of how i feel
about accessory accessory is something
that kind of adds on but i think of an
accessory is more of like a watch or a
purse or something not as much as a an
element to kind of go above and beyond
the existing treatment i like i like the
word supplement here but let's keep
going a study from an arts and Health
Research Center in Canterbury England
followed a study from an arts and Health
Research Center in Canterbury England
followed the progress of patients
diagnosed with depression for a year
after they joined a choir sixty percent
of patients reported improved mental
health at the end of the year and some
were no longer experiencing suffering
from clinical depression so experiencing
suffering and that sounds weird you you
i would say we're no longer suffering
from clinical depression maybe or no
longer experiencing symptoms of clinical
depression but I wouldn't have
experiencing and suffering there I would
get rid of one of them let's see what
what our options are were so and some
were no longer reporting that they were
suffering from clinical depression I
mean that reads well they and some were
no longer reporting that they were
suffering from clinical depression but
it still feels a little bit heavy you
know reporting that they were suffering
is that necessarily you could just say
some are no longer suffering let's see
this next one and some were no longer
suffering from clinical depression by
the end of the year well this one was
tempting but we already said at that at
the end of the year at the end of that
year and then to say by the end of that
year again sixty percent of patients
reported mental health at the end of
that year and some were no longer
suffering kalitta clinical depression by
the end of that year you're saying by
the end of that year twice that seemed
thats redundant if it just said
suffering from clinical depression I
actually wouldn't mind this choice let's
I hope d works out well sixty percent of
patients reported improved mental health
at the end of that year and some were no
longer clinically depressed yeah that
feels good nice and clean gets the point
across alright so we've answered through
nine but we've got to remember we
skipped 5 because 5 is about well what's
what's a good topic sentence for that
entire for that entire paragraph so
everything they talked about up here
they're just talking about hey look it
makes people feel feelings of pleasure
and do they even see it in the
endorphins you feel less stressed the
stress hormone gets decreases you feel
feeling of emotional bonding goes up and
you know then to give even more evidence
they say the researchers have even used
it to to help alleviate to deal with
depression and chronic pain so let's see
these choices singing in a choir can
help prevent depression well that's the
second half of the paragraph does talk
about that but that's not the whole
paragraph the whole paragraph isn't just
about depression that they are using
depression as an example of how singing
in a choir can make you feel better so I
wouldn't say that this is a topic if
this was a topic sentence I don't know
whether I would go as heavily on all of
this other stuff here I'd probably just
start right over here let's see the
brain tends to respond favorably to
group singing yeah I think I think this
is good the brain tends to respond
favorably to group singing this is
that's let's see how that reads the
brain tends to respond favorably to
group singing singing stimulates the
right temporal lobe of the brain
releases endorphins yet where we go
straight into talking about the brain
and dwarf ins brunt plane and engender
blunt pain and engender feelings of
pleasure so we're talking about all
these ways at the brain reacts and even
when we're talking about depression
we're talking about how it helps the
brain a deal with these things so yeah i
like i like choice see there so yeah
we've done all the way through question
9 so in the next video we can do the
last few questions